محكمه لاهور العليا تمنح خان حمايه قضائيه
لمده اسبوع تحول دون اعتقاله في التاسع
ومحاضر فتحت ضده بتهم مختلفه وشرطه لهور
في هذه الانباء العاجله نقلا عن مراسلات
تطلق قنابل الغاز لتفريق المتظاهرين اذا
في محيط المجمع القضائي في اسلام اباد
سنتوقف عند المزيد من التفاصيل مع شبكه
مراسلين نبدا بالوضع في لاهور مع مدير
مكتبه الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر حول الاوضاع
وما شهدته لاهورد ضمن سياق هذه الازمه عبد
الرحمن
صباح السبت وعلى مدى تقريبا ثلاث ساعات
متواصله وحتى الان بالمناسبه شرطه مدينه
لاهور اغلقت بالكامل كافه الحي السكني
الذي يقطن في عمران خان وعمدت بالتعاون مع
الاداره المحليه في مدينه لاهور لازاله كل
ما تصفه الحكومه او الشرطه بمخالفات
اجرائيه كان
مؤيدين عمران خان قد ارتكبوها خلال الفتره
الماضيه قاموا بعد ذلك بتحطيم البوابه
الرئيسيه البوابه الرئيسيه لمنزل عمران
خان بحجه ان افراد الشرطه تعرضوا لاطلاق
نار كما تشاهدون هنا كانت البوابه التي تم
تحطيمها بالكامل وفي داخل المكان الان بعد
ان انسحبت الشرطه الى حد ما من المنزل
لكنها ما تزال موجوده في محيط المنطقه
تشاهدون الان اعداد كبيره جدا من اعضاء
حزب انصاب بزعامه عمران خان وعدد سكان
المنطقه الذين قدمه هنا للتعبير عن
تاييدهم
لامران خان ولما حدث ورفض بالتاكيد لما
حدث كنا قد تحدثنا قبل قليل مع شقيقتي
عمران خان السيده عظمى والسيده نورين
وكلاهما كان موجودا في البيت عند الاقتحام
بالتاكيد ان يكون هناك اطلاق نار من داخل
البيت كما تقول الشرطه لكن على كل حال
الشرطه ايضا قالت بان فريق التحقيق
الجنائي الذي تمكن من جمع بعض الادله من
داخل البيت اكد مصادرته عدد من الاسلحه
وايضا كميه من الذخائر من داخل منزل عمران
خان كما تشاهدون حاليا اعداد كبيره من
المؤيدين اعداد كبيره من الاعلاميين ورجال
الصحافه لكن بالتاكيد يبقى الوضع الى حد
ما متوتر بالرغم من ان الشرطه حاليا
انسحبت من هذه المنطقه او من هذا البيت
تحديدا وهي موجوده في الخارج ولا تزال
معظم الطرق المؤديه الى منزل عمران خان
هنا في مدينه لهور مغرقه بالكامل بالرغم
من ان
محاولات رفع على انقاذ ومحاولات تطهير
المنطقه بحسب المصطلح المستخدم هنا ما
تزال متواصله الى حد ما لكن على الاقل في
هذه المنطقه او داخل البيت الان الوضع الى
حد ما هادئ الكل هنا يعبر عن
تضامنه مع خان ومع عائلته لكن هناك
بالتاكيد حاله من الغضب هناك دعوات الان
لاجراء التحقيق فيما يتعلق بما حدث اليوم
هنا في الهور وتحديدا في منزل عمران خان
هنا نعم اذا التوتر ينتقل ايضا عبد الرحمن
الى اسلام اباد خاصه مع اطلاق قنابل الغاز
من قبل الشرطه التفريق المتظاهرين في محيط
المجمع القضائي المنتضمنين مع عمران خان
وهنا ننتقل اليك سمير النمري كيف تبدي
الصوره الان
[موسيقى]
للتو قدمت من محيط المجمع القضائي هناك
حاله من الفوضى العارمه في كل محيط المجمع
انصار عمران خان الذين قدموا معه في موكبه
يقذفون الشرطه بالحجاره بينما هي تقوم
بالرد عليهم باستخدام قنابل الغاز المسيل
قامت ايضا باغلاق معظم الطرقات وبعظم
الشوارع المحيطه بالمجمع كانت هناك احداث
شغب كبيره
اتضرر ايضا المدنيين باستنشاقهم لكميات
كبيره من الغاز لم يعرف حتى الان ما اذا
كان عمران خان قد دخل الى قاعه المحكمه ام
لا زال في الخارج بسبب تلك الفوضى كان
هناك الالاف من المتظاهرين في محيط المجمع
القضائي وكان هناك حاله من الشغب وحاله من
الكر والفر بين المتظاهرين والشرطه التي
كانت تحاول ابعادهم عن محيط ذلك المكان
ربما يتضح خلال الساعات القادمه ما اذا
كان عمران خان قد مثل فعلا امام القاضي في
المحكمه وماذا صارت تلك المحاكمه بطريقه
طبيعيه ام ان تلك الفوضى التي لا زالت
مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه قد تعيق عمليه
المحاكمه وبالتالي قد يصدر القاضي قرارا
بارجائها الى يوم غد او ربما ايام اخرى
كانت السلطات ايضا قد قامت بقطع خدمه
الانترنت في كل محيط المجمع القضائي في
مسعن لايقاف عمليه التواصل ربما بين
المتظاهرين الذين لا زالوا يتوافدون الى
محيط المجمع القضائي رغم قرار الشرطه الذي
اتخذته صباح اليوم الذي يقضي باعلان حاله
الطوارئ في العاصمه
بما في ذلك منع التجمعات منع حمله الاسلحه
وهي تهدف كذلك من خلال هذا القانون الى
ايقاف التدفق البشري الذي قدم مع رئيس
الوزراء السابق الى محيط المحكمه نعم
سنعود اليك بطبيعه الحال في حال جد اي
جديد شكرا لك من اسلام نبات سمير النمري
ومن لاهور عبد اللحمدان مطر شكرا لكم